today I'm going to be talking about
tweetdeck tweetdeck basically just a
tool to help you manage twitter and use
it more effectively so before I show it
to you and how it worked let's have a
look first at what Twitter normally
looks low and what's good about it but
why you might not want to use it so this
is my home feed as you can see and if I
want to move and have a look at
different things I can have a look at my
own feed all of the tweets that I've
produced and that's that's that's fine
there and I can see on these suggestions
here and I can look at notifications and
see what kinds of activities happening
that are relates to me and that's all
fine now the issue with this is that
they present a lot of information here
in this one column but if I want to look
at something else I've got to go to a
completely different page to access like
my own feel like the notifications or
like I've been doing recently because
I've been hosting you if I want to
search up a hashtag I've got to go to
search and search for the term and then
it'll come up and I can have a look at
what's happening okay but then if i get
notification I'll go to the
notifications tab and then I'll say
what's happening and then in order to
get back into it I've got to search for
edge retweet eyes again and then it's
sort of a bit of a cumbersome process so
ah TweetDeck is basically designed to
allow you to do a whole bunch of these
things and see a whole bunch of these
things all at the same time so if you go
to tweet deck twitter com and then
simply side him with your existing a
Twitter account it'll pull everything in
for you and when you do that the very
first time you login is tweetdeck it'll
look like this now it is a bit
overwhelming the first time you see it a
little bit especially if you'd be using
to it for a while you're used to seeing
everything just as one column but have a
look at what's going on the headings
here are helpful home simply corresponds
to your home tab in normal to know this
is all the people who you follow and
what's going on retweets and pictures
and all that kind of thing that's the
home column here notifications this
column is exactly what it sounds like
you've got direct messages here and
activity is kind that current policy if
you went
to discover and you can go to activity
here which tells you what people who
you're following favorite team and who
they're following and what they do all
that kind of thing okay so that's the
default view now I actually don't tend
to like having my messages there all the
time so if I click up in the top right
put it here I can remove this column and
activity of my people are following also
is it something I look at all that much
so I'm going to remove that and now I
have all this extra space so I can fill
that with whatever I want so for
instance I pick over here to add column
you can choose all these different
things that you can add which will cover
for instance you could just have if
there's a particular person who you love
will get their tweets all the time or
maybe a news site that you don't updates
quite frequently you could pick user you
can pick trending which will just tell
you whatever is popular at the time what
I tend to use it for is a search so for
instance I want to search for all of the
hashtag EG tweet eyes tweets so if i add
that column there now anything that
anyone posts on hashtag videos will come
up automatically i don't have to refresh
the page ruthie and at the same time one
another one that I like to follow is a
chat it's pretty useful and it'll search
for a few that'll tell you what it finds
there you go ok now I've got space for
four columns here you can see this your
content coming up but there's no you can
you can put as many columns as you like
so far is it's falling to add another
column I want to search for say since
I'm a math teacher I could searchable
map chat I could put that on there I
could add that column and it just will
add all over on the brain so I can
switch between columns I know some
people who use six or seven columns
actually just whatever tickles your
fancy obviously you actually have the
option to move these around so if you
click on the top left you can cut up on
any of the cons for example if I want
match at to be further over here I can
strag that over and you'll change
position for me and I can do that with
any of them or I
get rid of that again and I can
customize it as I see fit so you can
even include additional accounts if you
want so you can go to settings and I you
can add a curt so add Twitter account as
you can see because I'm hosting at the
moment I have any tweet I was added in
there so that allows me if I wanted to
to see the home feed and the
notifications for that as well as for my
normal account so even though it's a bit
overwhelming to begin with having so
much information in front of you I
actually find it more helpful because I
don't have to flick between different
tabs different pages you want to see
what's going on it's all in front of me
at one view so that's why I like it and
I think it's a really helpful tool and
if you have more questions about it
please let me know